the law of total probability is a
another probability law that gives you
away a reason about cases which we've
seen is a fundamental technique for
dealing with all sorts of problems so
the point of cases of course is that you
can prove a complicated thing by
breaking it up into if you're lucky easy
sub cases so here's the way to
understand the law of total probability
abstractly it's not so if we'd set
theoretic reasoning suppose that I have
a set a embedded in some larger sample
space s so a is really an event but
we're just gonna think of it as a set
now suppose that I have three sets b1 b2
and b3 that partition the sample space
that is b1 b2 and b3 don't overlap
they're disjoint and everything is in
one of those three sets so there's a
picture of b1 b2 and b3 cutting up the
whole sample space s represented by the
square or rectangle okay now of course
these three sets that cut up the whole
space willy-nilly cut up the set a into
three pieces the first pace is the
points in a that are in b1 the second
piece is the points in a that are in b2
and the third is the points in a that
are in b3 so that's why we get a basic
set-theoretic identity that says that as
long as b1 b2 and b3 have the property
that their union is the universe
everything and their pairwise disjoint
then any set a is equal to the union of
the part of a that's in b1 the part of a
that's in b2 the part of a listen b3 and
this is a disjoint Union because the B's
don't overlap that means that if I was
talking about cardinality I could add
them up but in terms of probability I
can apply the sum rule for probabilities
and discover that the probability of a
is simply the probability of being 1
intersection a be 2 intersection a be 3
intersection a
now the most useful form of the law of
total probability is when you replace
this intersection B 1 intersection a by
the conditional probability using the
product rule so let's replace it by the
probability of a given B 1 times the
probability of B 1 that's just then
that's another formula for it B 1
intersection a and if I do that with the
rest of them I now have the law of total
probability stated in the usual way in
terms of conditional probabilities where
it's most useful no I did it for 3 sets
but it obviously works for any finite
number of sets as a matter of fact it
works fine for any countable union of
sets if I have a partition of the sample
space s into B 0 B 1 and so on a
partition with a countable number of
blocks then it's still the case that the
probability of a is equal by the sum
rule to the probability of these
disjoint pieces the parts of a that are
in each of the different blocks of the
partition and reformulating that as a
conditional probability I get the rule
that the probability of a is the sum
over all possible I of the probability
of a given B I times the probability of
B I and that basic rule is one that
we're going to get a lot of mileage out
of when we turn in the next segment to
analyze and understand the results of
tests that are maybe unreliable